[UPBEAT MUSIC]
JEREMY CONDIT: My
name is Jeremy Condit.
And I'm an engineering
manager on the BigQuery team.
Fun fact about BigQuery,
lots of Google Cloud products
had Big code names like BigStore
for storage and BigCluster
for compute that all
fell by the wayside
when those products launched.
When it came time
to launch BigQuery,
we considered renaming it.
But in the end, we decided
that there was no better way
to describe the unique power of
our product than Big and Query.
So the name stuck and
the rest is history.
JORDAN TIGANI: My
name is Jordan Tigani.
And I'm the director of product
management for Google BigQuery.
I was one of the founding
engineers on BigQuery
10 years ago now.
One of the most
memorable moments for me
was at Google I/O in 2014
where Felipe Hoffa and I
used BigQuery on
stage to predict
the results of the next eight
World Cup matches in Brazil.
We ended up getting all of
those predictions right.
And yes, the US did
lose to Belgium.
But it is possibly the
most stressful time
in my BigQuery career.
DAN DELOREY: I'm Dan Delorey.
I'm a senior engineering
manager on BigQuery.
I'll actually share my
fun fact about Dremel.
So for several years, I
was responsible for getting
internal users, Googlers,
to migrate onto Dremel.
At that time, we got
to 85% of Googlers
were using it on a monthly
basis and 75% on a weekly basis.
And I think that sort of
democratization of data
is really the benefit
that a tool like BigQuery
brings to organizations.
JING JING LONG: Hi, everyone.
I'm Jing Jing Long, the senior
staff engineer at Google.
One significant
innovation in BigQuery
that I'm particularly
proud of is BigQuery ML.
BigQuery ML enables users
to easily train and use
machine learning models inside
of BigQuery just using SQL.
We've seen customers be able
to reduce the amount of time
and effort it takes to create
a machine learning model
from months to days.
MOSHA PASUMANSKY: Hello.
I'm Mosha Pasumansky.
And I'm chief BigQuery
officer, meaning
I get to be involved in
all areas of BigQuery.
Really, I have the best job.
If you're getting
started with BigQuery,
you can go with many different
data warehouse designs.
You can do classic Kimball
schema or Data Vault or NoSQL
types of human
structured storage.
Really, they all
will work very well.
BigQuery knows how to
deal with all of them.
So do what makes sense
for your business model.
I recommend paying attention
to BigQuery's marquee features.
[INAUDIBLE] Data
Model, [INAUDIBLE],,
geospatial support,
ML, et cetera,
because they can significantly
improve your designs.
JEREMY CONDIT: I'm
proud to have been
able to contribute to
bringing the best of Google's
engineering expertise
to the world.
It's been an honor to be part of
a phenomenal team of engineers
dedicated to bringing
that experience
beyond the walls of Google.
Thanks.
JORDAN TIGANI: I just
want to finish up
by saying thank you to all the
BigQuery users and supporters
over the years.
You've been critical
to our success so far.
And with your help, I think
the next 10 years will
be as exciting as the last.
MOSHA PASUMANSKY: So big thank
you to our BigQuery users.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]